[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga it's been
a very public humbling for a once
triumphant Titan of tech in less than a
year Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg has
gone from celebrating the milestone of 2
billion monthly users to a two-day
grilling in both houses of Congress
following revelations that nearly 90
million Facebook users data was shared
with third parties without their
knowledge
Zuckerberg admitted it was my mistake
and I'm sorry breach of privacy hate
speech fake news election manipulation
are such abuses an inevitable result of
Facebook's business model is Zuckerberg
really prepared to take responsibility
or is it time for regulators to step in
Facebook the anti social network that's
our topic today on quadriga and these
are our guests it's a pleasure to
welcome grace dovish she is editor at
Honda's blot global and she says
Facebook is too big to regulate but if
we don't regulate it it will regulate us
it's a pleasure to have multi Leming on
the show once again he is senior editor
at the Berlin Daily the Tagus Spiegel
and he says Facebook is a business and
businesses want to make money and we're
very pleased to have with us our
colleague Karl Nessman he is editor at
DW and he says Facebook's problems are a
wake up call about our lack of privacy
on the Internet
let me start by asking you grace did you
think that the hearings that we have
just seen taking place in Congress will
they really change anything
I think the hearings showed us one thing
and that is that Mark Zuckerberg has the
real power here he was so well prepared
for any question they threw at him any
apologies that he gave were concessions
to the power of the US Congress but when
it comes down to it they have a
constituency of 300 million he has a
constituency of 2 billion people
what's Facebook is the biggest second
biggest country or something like that
in the world right just Facebook users
and
it seemed to me from watching those
hearings at first of all many of the the
lawmakers were almost deferential asking
for autographs in fact at some points
but the other thing that I noticed was
it wasn't just that Zuckerberg kind of
had the power but the lawmakers just
didn't really understand Facebook that
is it it's such a complicated business
model in a complicated company that he
had the power in that way as well that
no one really knew what questions to ask
multi living I know that you have
visited Facebook's
campus from what you saw there and from
watching these hearings take place this
week would you take Mark Zuckerberg at
his word when he says yes Facebook is
going to change its ways he did say when
Facebook got its two billionth monthly
user that the network definitely would
need to take expanding responsibility do
you think we'll see it do that two
billion monthly users is the biggest
country in the world not take a second
it is the biggest country in the world
so yes what I saw when I was there and
there were still these huge signs move
fast and break things don't be afraid
you had a working class of like 20 25 30
years old sneakers t-shirts and and and
the mood was just so we are hip we are
cool we are the new society we can
change the wall it's the hippie culture
mixing with the lot of money so I take
him by his word when he says I'm sorry
because I don't think that he really
wanted to to be a part of the Pro trumbo
probe X of course he is I think a
liberal and Facebook was misused by I
don't take him by his word when he's
saying we will change I think this has
to be that the proof is in part of you
you have to have to wait and see I don't
think I don't think that Congress will
do a lot to to really regulate Facebook
Christa were supposed to meet let me ask
you this as a business journalist
Facebook stock value has definitely
taken a hit some users have canceled
their accounts how serious and
widespread do you think the loss of
trust is I'm not sure that the loss of
trust is going to have an immediate
effect on the stock price the stock was
briefed
way up during the congressional hearings
I have a feeling that the reaction in
Europe is a quite a bit more strong than
in the United States in the United
States we almost don't have an
expectational privacy on the level that
Europeans do to some extent I assume
that my data has been compromised many
times over at this point what is there
to protect I don't know that there's
anything to protect but at the same time
you mentioned Mark Zuckerberg he's a his
apology was perhaps sincere whether he
will change who knows but the road to
this Facebook crisis is paved with good
intentions
right like they thought that they were
making something great for the world
they thought that they could change the
world and that type of optimism it's
really a new digital colonialism in a
way we have seen one thing and that's
that Facebook likes to make its own
rules
but that may not be the best procedure
for the future of humanity
speaking of wanting to change the world
we do have a short report on Facebook's
origins so let's take a quick look at
that
it all started small the wunderkind of
the tech sector founded his social
network for students while studying at
Harvard but Mark Zuckerberg had a big
vision connecting people around the
world for free Facebook became the
world's biggest social network making
Zuckerberg a billionaire in his
mid-twenties the network grew rapidly
along with criticism of it for years the
company has been accused of poor
transparency and privacy protection as
well as letting data be used for
propaganda purposes critics are also
disturbed by the fact that Facebook and
its founder stubbornly refused to accept
responsibility for the misuse of data
and attempts at manipulation the shy
tech pioneer briefly withdrew from the
public eye which just made the situation
worse
now his finally changed tack Zuckerberg
and his company promised improvements
saying that Facebook wants to again be
what he calls an optimistic company but
is that still possible so as we have now
discovered through the revelations of
the past week smelter looming what looks
free really isn't we simply pay with our
data the big question that still I think
is a very open question after those
hearings is can Facebook but book really
transform its business model or is it
not actually simply based on sharing
these data it is based on sharing these
data I mean they can't I would say they
can't change this business model their
business models give me her data and I
try to elaborate a a personalized
advertisement out of it and and that
this is where the profit comes from I
don't think they can change it they Mark
Zuckerberg hinted at one thing he says
ok we can talk about if you don't want
to give me your data you can pay for the
service so they are discussing this I
mean because it is a business model and
and it gives the consumer might even
give the consumer in the future the
choice to say no you don't I'm not
allowing you to to use my data for any
purpose at all but I'm willing to pay
for the service grace you and Carl as
well both said that you think in fact
many users are essentially complicit
either they don't care or they've become
fatalistic and just assume this is how
things work but is it not possible that
attitudes are changing and that more and
more users perhaps are now becoming
aware of the ramifications of this
business model and will demand changes
absolutely I think this is the first
time that the United States has really
had a discussion about what online
privacy means what sovereignty as a
person on the internet means these
everything that we know about the
internet currently is funded through
this attention economy we're paying with
our eyeballs we're paying with our data
whether there's another way forward I'm
not sure so
like Carl the scandal doesn't seem to
have hurt Facebook's ad business very
much we've heard from sheryl sandberg
that a few advertisers apparently are
pausing as she said right but in general
the ads are still coming in what does
that tell us yeah I mean I think
Facebook controls you know around a
third of the ad market there's 2.2
billion monthly users so this is not
something that advertisers want to give
up I mean it's such a great tool for
them and Facebook's business model is is
very sophisticated it's one of the few
places where an advertiser can go
advertise something and then know for
sure if it actually worked they can
track their users all the way to an
online store and see if they actually
bought the product that they were
advertising so this isn't something that
that advertisers are going to give up
very easily I don't think but I think it
is true that consumers and people that
use Facebook are starting to think a
little bit more about the privacy
implications about this it's hard not to
when all the headlines this week have
been about mark zuckerberg testifying in
front of Congress maybe got a privacy is
in a way a very abstract term I mean you
don't feel the violation of data privacy
except you're personally attached by it
I mean for example if your employer's
hairs or some knowledge that you googled
for two years a certain kind of disease
then oh why does he know us then you
really feel what privacy data means but
as long as this doesn't happen it's just
a very abstract term let me ask all
three of you have you changed anything
about your own habits given what you've
learned about Facebook grace I over the
last few years I'm using Facebook less
than I was in the early years I direct
Facebook in 2005 when it was first
available to my University in the United
States I've been with it a long time I
find myself sharing less at the same
time I run some small businesses and as
a small business owner Facebook and
other social media have been so
essential in making it possible for
micro businesses to see success and so I
can't really extricate myself from
Facebook at all Carl I think a lot of
people in the same position they've been
using Facebook for so long it's not
something that you can just give up or
delete Facebook as we've seen that
hashtag kind of trending
online me personally I actually deleted
the Facebook app and the messenger app
from my phone same because of privacy
concerns that you see how these apps
kind of follow you around and and the
big privacy concessions you have to give
to these apps so I've deleted that and
we'll see where that takes me but I'm
not I'm not ready to give up on Facebook
yet I haven't changed anything because
I've never been part of Facebook I have
no Facebook account I have a Twitter
account which I use quite frequently but
but no Facebook it's a as an editor I
have the the great honor and lecture to
luxury to to publish my opinion whenever
I want so and I can stay in contact with
my friends in other terms like I think
the delete Facebook movement if you
could call it that is a bit
short-sighted people maybe have the
privilege to delete facebook but for
underprivileged populations or oppressed
populations especially say refugee
populations LGBT populations Facebook
and other social media are an essential
tool to connecting to communities that
you may not be geographically close to
and so we can't like it's a it's a death
sentence for some communities - I want
to come back to that point in just a
moment but one question to you Karl this
picks up essentially on what we heard in
those hearings again Mark Zuckerberg was
asked explicitly what exactly is
Facebook the the questioner said is it
more like advertising is it more like
publishing or is it perhaps even more
like a telecom utility what would be
your answer to that question I think
it's funny that what fourteen fifteen
years later we're still asking what is
Facebook right I mean we haven't figured
it out yet I think it keeps evolving
just like most tech companies and social
media companies it started off as a way
for university students to connect with
people now you know there's so many
things integrated you can send payments
you can do shopping you can watch TV
series now so it's a little bit of
everything I think Mark Zuckerberg
doesn't want to call it a media company
that opens it up for regulation but it's
becoming a media company it's a little
bit of journalism it's a little bit of
Commerce I think it's a bit of
everything and that is what makes it so
diff
I think for many US lawmakers to grasp
what Facebook is so multi looming
Zuckerberg answer was I consider us to
be a technology company I'm quoting here
the primary thing we do is have
engineers that write code and build
services for other people is that a
satisfactory answer at least I think
he's right
I mean they don't they don't produce
content they so they're different to a
media company or a publishing house so
they basically distribute content that
others are producing and they they do it
with a certain kind of algorithm they
invented in it's a but but but do they
really is it a media house I would be
very hesitant to call it like that I
would argue that it's more of a telecom
to be honest it's a method of
communication for many people it
distributes content sure but it's it's
maybe a new type of a new type of
category altogether but on the other
hand like a media house or a publishing
house it is influencing the the
perception of reality because of the
algorithm that puts some topics on the
top or not and and and where the party
is and with what people are talking
about they decide upon what kind of
topic is the hottest topic right now so
and this is influencing the perception
of reality so in a way they are more
than just distributing other people
contents let's take a brief look at the
direction of that influence picking up
on what you said earlier about
Facebook's role in creating bonds within
communities last year as Facebook hit
that to a billion user mark Mark
Zuckerberg said that he saw a new
mission for his company to bring the
world closer together but as we have
discovered that is a two-edged sword
social networks such as Twitter and
Facebook are platforms facilitating
communication between people individuals
can connect virtually to groups for the
purpose of following common goals
that has often resulted in protest
movements gathering strength or even in
revolutions like the 2010 Arab Spring
when Egyptians took to the streets
demanding freedom and human rights
protests on the scale of this one at
Tahrir Square could only be organized
through social media but there is a flip
side what happens when the social media
hive mind develops a mob mentality or
when people use social networks to break
the law like the terrorist organization
is which recruits new members through
these networks unobserved
[Music]
so what prevails the good parts or the
bad ones and let me put that question
right to you
grace is Facebook a boon or a bane for
democracy it's certainly changing the
way that we interact with each other and
with the wider world I do not know
whether how history will shake out Carl
interestingly enough after all the
revelations about what was happening in
terms of hate speech on Facebook and so
on
Germany told Facebook you know what you
are at least to some degree a media
company with a gatekeeper responsibility
and we expect you now to start hiring
editors to keep watch over the content
on your site hundreds of people have
been hired here in Germany to do what
Facebook claimed it wasn't in a position
to do edit content so what does that
tell us is it not possible for
regulators to take action and compel
Facebook to take the kind of
responsibility Mark Zuckerberg keeps
promising I think it is possible I think
Europe Germany is kind of leading the
way in terms of showing that large tech
companies should and can be regulated we
saw with the hate speech outcry here in
Germany when when people would report a
hateful comment or something uh you'd
see maybe a picture or video on Facebook
it wouldn't get taken down and now
there's tens of thousands of people
around the world working for faith for
Facebook doing that exact same thing
Zuckerberg keeps saying look it's all
about artificial intelligence this is
his solution he wants to see AI programs
scanning the network for maybe hate
speech or something that could be
anti-democratic I think it's part of the
solution but it's gonna be you need real
people to do this and make the kind of
judgement calls because it's difficult
for a robot or an algorithm to determine
what hate speech is I think it's just a
matter of moving some of those billions
of dollars at Facebook makes and and
putting that into an actual effort to
try to crack down on this stuff and I
think it's very very difficult and I'm
very critical about all the
I mean Facebook should should be a
marketplace and what are the criterias
do content have to be reasonable or
trustworthy or nice or how do you value
that we have criteria in terms of
constitutional protections we right here
in Germany the of human dignity is that
not a sufficient criteria international
technology the business models so we in
Germany have the denial of the Holocaust
for example the Turks have the denial of
the Amenia Holocaust the French have the
opposite the if you if you deny the the
denial of the emini another cows and so
on so every country is liberating its
own standards how can how can facebook
deal and and do you really want to to
give the power about what is allowed to
private people working with Facebook or
an algorithm I think it's very very
difficult
the fact is Europe has taken some very
concrete steps now it's new data
protection law is coming into effect in
just about a month and during these
hearings Mark Zuckerberg seemed to
indicate some willingness to look at
that as a possible model for what
Facebook could do internationally would
that be a solution grace for Facebook
and the u.s. perhaps to take a leaf from
Europe's page I think that that's just a
stopgap solution honestly I don't
I'm skeptical whether they will be able
to implement all of those changes in
time but also that it begs the question
why does Europe get to decide what these
privacy standards will be and likewise
why should facebook then decide whether
or how much it complies with these
standards I think there needs to be a
wider discussion about personal digital
identity around the world I don't want
any our digital identities right now
we're going through the gatekeeper of
Facebook or the gatekeeper of Twitter
we don't really own our digital
identities there's a wider discussion
happening now in tech circles especially
when it comes to data privacy about
idea of an autonomous digital identity
no idea what that looks like yet but is
that are you telling us there's a
technical solution for this we don't
need regulation I'm saying that it
cannot be regulated by a government
because we can see we see what
governments can do with the wrong type
of power it can't also be regulated by
any private company it needs to be a
larger non-governmental solution Carl
would you agree with that or would you
say that the kind of initiatives we're
seeing here in Europe potentially also
in the u.s. there is a snowballing
movement now even in the u.s. to say you
know what it's time to start thinking
about regulation do you see all of that
as ineffectual
I think regulation can be effective I
think there has to be some sort of
government regulation you can't just let
Facebook regulate itself we've been
letting Facebook do that for more than a
decade it hasn't worked clearly and I
think as soon as what we saw in terms of
potentially affecting the 2016 election
as soon as we've we've seen data being
leaked to shady companies that is kind
of what had to happen to wake people up
in the US and maybe even lawmakers the
problem is I don't I don't think that
Congress in the u.s. really wants to do
anything they haven't been very
effectual in it so it's interesting to
see the EU and I think it's a good thing
there's this new GDP our protection
regulation here in the EU they're doing
basically what the American and
politicians don't want to do they're
finally putting some some real
regulations down it's not going to be a
perfect regulation you I'm not sure that
there is one but it's it's a first step
and that needed to happen that needs to
tell Facebook hey look you know you need
to start to play to play ball with us I
think that's why Zuckerberg even went to
Congress in the first place he knows
that there is a legislation and
regulation on the way so he's there to
kind of shape it and he wants to be on
Capitol Hill to have his voice heard as
well it has to be the right kind of
regulation and he also said very very
expressly that he thinks if regulation
goes too far it will create a
competitive disadvantage visa vie China
particularly in regard to artificial
intelligence would you buy that argument
China
very far and so far he's right but I
would say what kind of regulation do we
need I think it's completely wrong to
put all the blame on the consumer he has
to be more informed inform himself and
and read through all these ten or twenty
pages in advance and if you sign yes or
no you have to give him clear choices
are you agreeing that your data is used
for personalized advertisement yes or no
do you agree that your data is used for
political advertisement and analyzed but
yes or no do you agree bubblebum clear
options clear yes or no questions
nothing else
don't put the black don't put all the
blame to the consumer put it to the to
Facebook saying this is what it would
we're talking about Greece dobisch there
is also some discussion now about
whether Facebook and the other big
Titans of tech Amazon Google have gotten
too big for their britches whether we
have seen a cartelization of the digital
economy on the basis of what's called
Network effects that in fact these
companies become much more attractive
the more users that they have question
would be will we see antitrust measures
coming in future even the Economist has
warned that they could be on the way I
think that that's a real possibility my
I was going to ask the question if
Facebook is getting regulated why not
Google Google has more than 2 billion
users of its Android platform billions
using Gmail Google Maps Chrome browser
all of these companies have gotten
larger than any companies the world has
seen before at the same time we're
focusing so much on these American
companies when $0.10 in China is nearly
nearly as large as some of these
companies I think that we can't ignore
the the worldwide implications of this
type of regulation at the same time I
don't know that piecemeal regulation of
these types of large companies is going
to be enough reminded a little bit of
the brilliant Brandenburg Airport you
know it's so big but you spent so much
time on it we keep on patching up the
little things we fixed the escalator but
when it comes down to it maybe we just
need to tear it all down and start from
them to get exactly Karl that would be
the question
is Facebook in essence too big to fail
and too big to regulate uh I don't I
don't know what that just seems so
fatalistic to me I think it's a big
company but look it's not just Facebook
as you mentioned you have Google yen and
I think even the next big company on the
way is Amazon with a they're putting
Alexa devices in everyone's living room
so it's not about regulating Facebook
it's about regulating our privacy and
regulating tech companies in general so
whatever be regulate with Facebook has
to then apply to all these other
companies as well that's really
important thank you very much to all of
you for being with us and thanks to all
of you out there for tuning in see you
soon
[Music]